[Music]
Chris out back in the house for another
edition of Coach's Corner yeah we've
gotten a lot of good feedback from it
there's a lot of demand
yeah episodes are super popular so it's
good to reprise this version of the
podcast man good to see you my friend
yeah good to see you I'm finally up at
the house I know all the years that
we've worked together and done
everything you've never even visited
before I think maybe there's probably
some people that don't that I think we
live in the same city but we don't know
no and I'm always down in Santa Monica
when I come visit cuz I see a few other
clients as well and so you've always
come down there right I think every
podcast we've done has been in a hotel
room actually that's true right they've
all been in the Georgian and after until
Oh we did it yeah in a cramped room
sitting on the bed yeah so now you have
this functional studio it's good excuse
to get you up no actually we did it at
the house in Tahoe oh that's right yeah
but technically I was kind of like yeah
exactly I forgot about that I still
gotta get Caroline on the show yeah
she's cool so before we launch into it
tell me how you're doing man what's
going on
I'm doing great it's uh it's been a busy
year I've signed up for a variety of
events yeah and just sort of want to see
what the body can do this year mm-hmm so
you're planning on returning to either
to the are you doing Iron Man Iron Man
first so I haven't done that and a
couple of years either right um I did
100k run a couple of weeks ago mm-hmm
sort of a ten-hour thing how did that go
well um I want to be careful this year
because as many ultra endurance athletes
know it's gonna be a long year if I get
into Ultraman and that's a big if right
and it's not that big of enough well I'm
keeping my fingers I'm holding the line
on that you'll be you'll be telling the
line this year okay good good and I'll
be crewing but that yes you will be yes
that's November and so if I'm to fit or
doing too much now or taxing the body
too much now I'm worried and I'm from
past history of knowing that I can't
maintain that until
you know November mm-hmm so I wanted to
be real smart during that first trail
race of the season and I just go out
there and keep steady energy for what
turned out to be 11 hours but that's
fine right then you got an Ironman
coming up so you're back on the bike
yeah in there in a real way for the
first time in a long time yeah and I
lost a lot of fitness I mean last year I
didn't do any real cycling we got ready
for too low I did a half ironman in
there but I mean you can sort of fake
your way through to two and a half hours
of biking but not through five yeah six
hours of biking and then Hotel cheating
on me with the new I checked with you
yeah no it was cool I gave you
permission yes you did this polyamorous
relationship and then yeah and then it
would be going to the Big Island yeah
that's cool is he honest doing Pattillo
again this year that I don't know that I
did not studies do an ultra matte but
he's still an ultra man yeah it's
interesting
it'll be fun and you know he'll be at
Attila even if he's not taking parts of
the horse there'll be some trees did it
this past year with his wife yeah so I'm
sure I think he's done in every year
hasn't he I'd be surprised by him that
he doesn't do it this year but remember
he did say to us last year at the dinner
after he's like I'm done I need a browse
to delirious never
I barely remember that conversation but
he'll he'll be there and he'll want to
rub it in a little bit yeah well on the
subject of Ultraman and we were talking
before the podcast with respect to you
know the volcano right now I'm you know
that that that's going down on a
significant part of the day to bike
course like I've ridden through that
area I know that area I believe lava has
flowed over the red road which is where
I crashed my bike it's the one part of
the race where the crew vehicles cannot
follow you because it's so pristine and
they want to preserve it that way so you
know it's insane what's going on there
this year no indication that the
eruptions are gonna stop anytime soon
and yet by all accounts
Ultraman is still planning on going
forward at this point so they're clearly
gonna have to reconfigure the
course yeah and I was saying to you
before the podcast that that's sort of
intriguing too because it's gonna create
this new course and new dynamics and you
know maybe different strategies at
different parts of the course parts of
it three days yeah without a doubt
I mean the the course really dictates
how you you know attack and plan so but
I think they'll keep the distances
exactly yes it's easy to do that in my
mind on the island to get us back to
Javy on day two
despite the riding up the volcano a
different volcano on day one so because
there's only really that one main road
to go around that side of the island so
it's not like you can go around it some
other way they're gonna have to
backtrack and figure out a different
route that remains on the western side
of the island yeah I would think but
didn't they they had to redo the course
one of the years that Gordo did it we
had different washed out or something
out right yeah so it's not the first
time they've had to do that but it's
gonna be interesting they know what
they're doing yeah cool well I put it
out on both of us put it out on social
media the other day that we were gonna
get together and what we wanted to do
was answer some listener questions so we
put it out on Twitter and Facebook we
got a ton of ton of questions Chris and
I need some notes and we're gonna go
through to the best of our ability you
know a few of them I mean there were
some consistent themes that kind of
emerged from that so they're gonna be
more kind of like topic specific that's
then then like super specific questions
but before we do that I thought I would
do something a little bit different
which is read this post that you sent to
me the other day called meaning can I do
that yeah I didn't I didn't know what
you said first of all you said to me in
an Evernote note but you should put this
you should publish this why don't you
put this on your blog what because it's
these are thoughts that are streaming
through my head lately and I trust you
in a lot of ways with regards to having
perspective with all this and sharing
with you I thought would give me some
good feedback if it's worthwhile
so clearly cool all right we'll read it
it's kind of long so I don't know take
me five minutes to read it but I think
it's worth reading because it's super
good man I think this is great stuff so
it's called meaning and it goes like
this
I feel as though there are so many out
there looking for meaning not in a
deeper spiritual way but instead that
they are missing something something
fulfilling something that sets their
wires straight I think that is why ultra
endurance and endurance world of
adventures events and expeditions has
gained so much appeal of late I believe
it satisfies these needs this sense of
purpose sense of living to our potential
this self realization that there is more
to us than sleeping eating and working /
career of course there is time for
family and in more rare cases
unfortunately for community and church
and more but one thing is missing in all
of this the self the time for self the
time for self help self health the time
for spending time with thoughts
reflection elevated heart rate muscular
activity and most importantly fresh air
nature endurance events allow for this
and more a connection with nature with
the environment with its beauty its
ability to revive us we are hard-wired
for nature to be outside to live
connected with our environment to feel
it to play and struggle in it to be
challenged by it and therefore challenge
ourselves this sense of adventure
challenge struggle and realization is
what pulls people to becoming endurance
athletes to discover their potential at
first maybe not a huge step but seeing
what we are capable of and growing from
there to a new potential and all the
while connecting to our truest raus
inner self how we are hard-wired as
animals to nature to the outdoors to a
sense of feeling alive in it via
activity everything is active around us
in nature and of course we as humans are
part of this nature part of this growth
and vibrant balance and as the athlete
continues to grow to new challenges
which then adds some fear and curiosity
and uncertainty to it which again brings
us back to our true raw self that human
living with the outdoors surviving
outdoors and feeling most alive when we
are truly challenged physically and
mentally
via nature and our endeavors in it
nothing can replace that as it is our
truest raw self it's very deep down
there but the more athletes connect with
it the more they realize how much that
dormant self was in them and they want
to unlock and unleash more it makes them
better more energetic healthier happier
more creative more efficient more
connected and therefore caring the
stewardship of our environment and
nature begins with loving our self in it
and feeling this connection to it
how can one relate to environment and
it's the environment and its destruction
if one is foreign when in it but when we
have felt how we are truly part of it
that is a deeply connected and wired
part of us we begin to unlock this
hardwiring and allow it to fire more and
more in order to feel alive and joyful
and happy and motivated in our days not
only to get out and spend time in it
again but revitalized for work and
family and community and more because
our own tank of self-care is full and we
are connected and seeing and feeling our
potential physically and emotionally
we need the fresh air for all of that to
fire as I heard the other day in order
to love others we need to love ourselves
we can't give more love than we are able
to give ourselves so knowing that we
have this emptiness and missing
component in our lives makes living
generously and giving very hard we are
missing something that huge piece is our
hardwired self for outdoor adventure
physical activity and with that comes
curiosity with what we could be capable
of awakening the endurance athlete
within the one that is curious if they
can achieve that goal and once seeing
that growing to a new level of
appreciation of that better healthier
more confident beautiful vibrant
energetic self that close outward
because on the inside the fire of that
missing component has been lit the
challenges we feel this imbalance we
can't we just can't identify what it is
we have become so disconnected with our
potentials that we don't know how to
explain what it is but most once outside
in nature training with a healthy fear
to
an event on the outer edge of their
current capability start to understand I
was reading the other day about how we
no longer have these rites of passage
that young men and women used to go on
out in nature surviving on our own
living in the world of our environment
off the land for days to really feel it
sleep in it awaken it live off of it and
immerse ourselves in it we no longer
have this and it might be leaving a
curious hole in our soul that is missing
why is it we are so curious and
mystified by the outdoor life adventures
raw ability in nature when we see those
pictures or here are the stories that it
tugs at us that it leaves us daydreaming
because we are drawn to it it is who we
are how we are hard-wired from thousands
of years of living in nature in balance
with it surviving in it being challenged
by it being overwhelmed by it feeling
alive on the ocean or in the woods in
the mountains or the desert it all has
its effect on us we all think back to
the beautiful moments outdoors alive
have we been sterilized to our fake
lighting fake transportation fake
shelters fake space we call our property
we have ignored this fundamental part of
us for too long where is our danger our
use of all our senses or unease our
unease where are we truly challenged in
body mind and soul not at work not at
home but in play in the outdoors or
anything close to it your senses come
alive ever so gradually all the
components and cells of your body start
weakening and firing because that is
where we are originally from land sea
air coming back from this dose it fires
all our senses no treadmill or gym can
replace this their time passes slowly
laborious ly in nature time passes
quickly because we get lost in ourselves
and our thoughts in mind and spirit in
listening to our body and soul it's all
happening there how do you think we feel
after a marathon or 50k in the woods
mountains or beautiful terrain how do
you think we feel after a day on the
oceans or lake
rowing sailing swimming fully powering
ourselves across terrain mountain biking
through hills and meadows across streams
repeat any of these actions for a few
days in a row and our sense of self
changes our priorities shift our soul
exhales and relaxes to what it knows is
an integral part of it
nature challenge raw beauty and
immersive inputs all around us we all
have an impulse to be more an impetus we
often don't know why or where it came
from but it is their adversity creates
morality it shows our human side
vulnerability and therefore empathy
that's beautiful man thank you thank you
that's poetry that different hearing it
yeah someone read it ha ha ha it's very
powerful that yeah it's great man well
that's the first time I've like read
something on the podcast and went off on
a monologue but I was I was moved by it
I'm touched by that and I thought it was
worth worth reading so well thanks how
many more well I just I've come across
so many athletes over the last two three
years that have different adventures
planned in their lives and how they
communicated to me and the excitement
they explained it with is less about
getting a placing or a result or
qualifying for something or you know
hitting a certain time it's more about
finding out who they are achieving a
desired outcome a lot of times I've been
talking less about goals for people and
more desired outcomes because it keeps
it flowing it keeps it moving and it
shows the growth and a lot of times the
athletes that come to me they realized
they didn't know what it was that was
tugging at them but something they're
more curious about and I believe it's
this piece it's finding out ourself
potential or what we can be and like for
example the other day I'm listening to
the podcast with you and Michael mm-hmm
you guys would talk about optimization
and self-realization and that growth
right and I think in many cases people
don't know what that is tugging at then
to optimize to grow but there's this
part that's been missing and then we're
all hardwired to be outside alive
immersed and like I was writing when
we're out there you notice it when
you're cycling 20 30 40 minutes and you
start to notice cars around you without
hearing am I seeing them you just get
your senses are all alive when you're in
water for a while swimming open water or
even in a pool things change in your
body as well as your mind we're meant to
be out there doing these things and
that's what I love this curiosity people
are realizing I want to find out what
I'm capable of what's out there what's
more in me and grow that right yeah I
think you've completely nailed it and
you know we were also talking before the
podcast about how more and more of your
athletes are now embarking on you know
adventures of their own self styling or
you know bizarre things that you've
never coached anyone for it used to just
be you know a marathon an Ironman an
Olympic triathlon or something like that
and now you're seeing much more
diversity and creativity in this space
and I think it's exactly what you're
talking about and I also think it's that
yearning for more like that person who
maybe doesn't understand
self-realization or doesn't really have
their finger on the pulse of what
exactly is tugging them their first
impulse might be like they have that
yearning they don't know exactly what
quite what it is so I'll sign it for a
race I'll do a 10k like I'm I want to be
in the top of my age group but that's
not really what it's about
yeah it's that piece that's missing
inside of them to connect with that part
of who we are who we've always been
that's the pole right and once you've
kind of explored some of those races and
then you go yeah that was cool and I did
learn a lot about myself but like how
can I get more out there how can I get
more in touch with myself and that comes
through you know these these adventures
that are much more about Nate and like
that was one thing that was beautiful
about Attila like yeah it's a race but
it was it was about the surroundings and
this incredible landscape that I never
would have visit
there you know so if when it starts to
become more about that like your your
your blinders come off and you're kind
of consciousness expands and I think
once you've had a taste of that that's
really where the allure comes from and
you think less about the results right
and you think more about being out there
and this is a this is an evolution for
you as well as an athlete it's a super
hardcore yes you know German raised yeah
precision machine many people have said
that to me like Melo are you yeah now I
have the title of this podcast the
mellowing of Chris
yeah and it's it's it's been really fun
to watch that change not only in me
because I'm able to coach people
differently um more in the mindset and
more getting them out there and more
balanced right there's another thing a
little and maybe a little more empathy
yes that was a that's a new word yes I
used it it's the last word in this entry
and I was like wow wow Chris is using
the word empathy but it has it has come
into it a lot because as I talk more and
more about balance with regards to
family with regards to career and this
ultra-endurance world that we're in it's
hard to be able to continue to do all
three at a high level yeah it's just not
possible
and like I keep saying I call it the
three-legged stool and one's career
one's family and ones are personal
sports endeavors or whatever interest
hobbies say well it doesn't need to be
this crazy ultra endurance thing and I
don't necessarily think it always needs
to be a level one leg of the stool can
be shorter and the other one can be
longer but the stool is still in balance
you might have more family demands
sickness family issues whatever that
will require more of your time the other
two will have to back off a bit mmm
right doesn't mean this law isn't
balanced or there's a time in your life
where we have time to do a lot of ultra
endurance to find the hours to do this
stuff and then the other leg shortens a
bit but you can't keep those things at
bay for too long in a perfect balance
otherwise they will all give ya and a
perfect example of that
is why I'm not racing Oh Atilla with you
this year people right well why aren't
you going back it's like alright well
one one is I did it so I don't I don't
have the same poll to return to that but
there's a season for everything and this
year I had other things that I wanted to
focus on and and because you know
balance is a fickle lover for me like
once I commit and I'm all-in
it sort of blinds me to other other
things in my life and and that's what I
love about it like I can go all-in on
something and I want to see how I'm
going to perform but this year I wanted
to attune that level of attention to
other things in my life and I'm
travelling like crazy like it just
didn't it wasn't gonna be you know a
positive outcome for me to try to do all
of that this year you know next year
there's something that I want to do and
and my balance equation will shift
towards that but this year it's
just about traveling we just got back
from Italy and I'm on the road like all
the time and I've got kids that are
aging up and you know there's other
things in life that are important to
attune to and I say that as somebody who
who's not great at the traditional
notion of what balance is and that's
something that you know I talked to
Michael about on the last podcast and he
had a great answer which is forget about
balance like worry about being present
and whatever it is that you're doing or
that you choose to do
and with this balance because I like to
call it balance is um that you don't
feel guilty or overwhelmed that you're
not doing all things great there's times
when other things require more of your
attention right like currently your work
and travel and all that is requiring
more of your attention you're okay with
putting the ultra on side cuz you've
been there you know you can turn it up
again or turn it down again it's not
that foreign to you and so it puts you
more present for what you're doing now
yes right and then career mine our
family might change the dynamics and you
need more time there but again I know I
can dial up career I know I can dial up
interns I can dial that back and that
calmness that ease that you have inside
without that guilt of oh my god I'm
gonna miss a workout yes you've been
there we've all been there words like I
don't
anything that take away from my hours of
the week like it's impossible to live
like that you can't keep pulling from
that well in that resource it will drain
and dry out yeah I mean you can do it
for a short truncated period of time but
it also it creates a lot of stress and
anxiety depending upon you know how busy
you are on the other areas of your life
and you wake up a couple years later
going what was I yeah I just did the
same thing for the last seven years and
I know that's that battle you can't stay
in the same spot so as somebody who's
bit who's always been an athlete I mean
you literally never retired you went
straight from being an Olympic swimmer
into professional being a professional
triathlete now coach continuing to
compete ultras like you literally have
never you've gone through phases of
varying intensity but it's not like you
ever took a break and stopped so what is
it that you still continue to learn
about yourself and others by virtue of
being immersed in this world there's
always something I'm learning these
events are also all so different that
there's always something new to add to
the portfolio of learning with regards
to coaching as well I mean what we
learned last year in attila the whole
concept to swim run and that as
cross-training for a lot of other events
is has been very valuable yeah I think
the biggest lesson that you learned at
Attila is like patient it was the first
time you had to do a race with somebody
else and I was dragging you down and you
had to learn how to like be cool with
that which my own you know it's
important and hardest lesson for you is
just gonna say the same thing like that
was a very meaning like when I look back
many months ago about what happened
there I learned a ton from that if
anything I have to thank you because I
learned to just let go and not just be
focused on my outcome and of course it
was always our outcome together but I
identified with her with a result and
wasn't the lesson that I was that I
really wanted to be teaching you that
day but again there was something we
learned in that and so back to your
question with regards to what am I still
learning these days my athletes are
bringing me so many
different adventures I mean there's not
a week that doesn't go by where my
athletes aren't researching what they
want to do next and they send me this
bizarre race in like Mongolia and I'm
like oh that's sort of cool how would we
prepare for that and so then I start
going out and doing some of the training
blocks for that out of curiosity to how
I'm responding to that and now order and
then to apply it to them right I mean
that the part that I need in my coaching
is having gone through it because it
really allows me to connect with what
I'm thinking what I'm observing and then
can connect with the athlete to calm
them and build confidence in them that
we're gonna do this because I've been
there I've felt it and we'll be fine
right from the experience in Sweden last
year and as somebody who's going back
this year what did you what did you take
away just sort of tactically and
training wise that you're incorporating
into your preparation for that race this
year because you know we talked about
this before but the whole the the
technical aspect of the running totally
threw me for a loop
it was like I thought we were gonna be
trail running you know and it wasn't
anything like that and I was like man I
would have done a lot you know a bunch
of different kind of strength training
stuff which I'm doing this year a
different type of strength training um
and as well as more vertical and lateral
stuff with regards to our the jumping
that we did the side rocks box jumps
moving sideways burpees the other day we
had a swim practice what we had to get
out of the pool not just do the push-up
but completely get out and sure enough I
had everybody in my lane doing burpees
because if we're gonna do this if we're
gonna get out might as well do some
intensity and I heart rate with it yeah
I'm and then go back in and swim the 400
and so forth but no I think it's more
being able to handle the impact and
stresses of that day on the lower legs
core stability lower leg strength and so
forth right cool all right well let's uh
let's take some questions from the
audience yeah you want to do that so we
made some notes here and there more like
I said they're more like themed attic or
topical but you know maybe the first
thing that we can kind of talk about and
we have a whole list here I don't know
how many
we're gonna get through but we're not
doctors that's what they know yeah there
are a couple very specific questions
that require somebody with medical
education that yeah and and it's not our
place to give advice even if it's
high-level advice on that because when
it comes to certain things you want to
have clear insights from a medical
professional with regards right heart
rate there was one question that that I
think was worthy of discussing because
there's a lot of confusion around it
which is stretching should you stretch
and if you should should you do it
before you workout after your workout
what's your thoughts on that because
there's isn't there was like a
conventional wisdom swimming around for
a lot like when we grew up the swimmers
it was all about stretching yes and then
there was a period of time where it was
like if you're a runner you should not
stretch it but I think this attention to
stretching is now coming back yeah yeah
I'm I'm definitely a believer in
stretching I don't believe in the old
school stretching before you're even
warm enough and going right if anything
the muscles have to be warmed up loose
supple and you're able to use the effect
of a of a warmed up muscle to stretch it
I personally prefer and recommend my
athletes stretch after their workout in
order to we tune themselves with their
body see where the niggles are sort of
get that recalibration going
did you ever experiment or buy into that
idea that stretching is bad I did you
did I did I've made plenty of mistakes
yeah over the last 25 years and you know
the part that why I brought it up is
where I've noticed stretching can cause
issues that if the muscle is not warmed
up you are doing little micro tears yeah
and the likely injure yourself the
likelihood of those micro tears in the
muscle goes way up I'm not saying you
will but it goes way up the likelihood
if you're not relaxed loosened up warm
mmm blood flow yeah I was somebody who's
always been super flexible naturally and
that
lent itself you know in swimming where
flexibility is a big part of it and then
for for a couple years I did that thing
where I was like okay well they're
saying that if you're running a lot you
shouldn't stretch and I didn't do it and
and then I lost a lot of that
flexibility and I've been trying to get
back to it and regain that because I
think that that lack of flexibility has
led to some imbalances and some problems
that I've had to work through so I think
it's super important and you know when
your time crunched it's the thing you
don't want to do or you want to blow off
or what-have-you but I think it's super
important yeah and I'm a proponent of
anything where you're tuning in with
your body you're taking a moment to
listen to it and hear what's going on
and stretching will tell you that where
you're looser where you're tighter what
side you can do something on you can't
do it as well on the other side little
things like that they're just part of
that bigger picture of listening to your
body what it's expressing itself to you
right recovery huge huge fan of recovery
so for somebody who's who's just trying
to wrap their head around maybe they're
new to the world of endurance sports
their time crunched what is what is some
I mean this is this tricky to get into
because it's so persons specific like
how hard are you training how
experienced are you like etc but if
there are some general principles
guiding principles around how to recover
and some techniques around recovery that
you could share well sleeping is by far
the most important component there what
happens in your body while you're
sleeping cannot be replaced by any
supplements by any shakes by anything
out there ma I'm also a big proponent of
recovery days it's so hard for so many
athletes to just take a day off and the
constant theme and the feedback from
those days is well I almost feel worse
on days I'm not doing anything I like to
just get a little blood flow going and
be when I come back to training let's
say after a day or two off I feel
lethargic and slow and disconnected well
that just shows how far in a hole we
probably were it's like that adage
you go on vacation and you don't set an
alarm clock and then you notice actually
how much sleep you need it's the same
thing with a day off or two days off
from especially an ultra endurance
training because we get to the state of
I wouldn't call it numbness but it's
this overall fatigue that we don't
realize how deeply fatigued we are until
we take a few days off and get some good
sleep yeah and I think in the in this
world it attracts a lot of very driven
type-a personality people and it
requires a different kind of discipline
to put the brakes on and slow down and I
think the kind you know the extent of
your recovery comes with like
understanding how much you how much
recovery you need and how to do it
really just comes with experience
it comes with experience and again back
to the theme that we're probably gonna
have on all these questions is listening
to your body there's a lot of ways
beyond your morning resting heart rate
beyond beyond your general data that you
can use to see how you're responding to
the training and therefore if you need
recovery one of those being how much
you're eating your hunger is a huge sign
of how you're you're absorbing the
training load or not your sleep needs
and what time you're going to bed as
well as how you're waking up and how
lethargic you are your heart rate during
the training if it's super low and
suppressed and just won't respond
despite doing some higher intensity
efforts those are all starting to be
signs that you're on the far end of what
I call overreaching you're not
overtraining but you're getting to that
edge you're overreaching the edge right
and as we know from a variety of
publications out there is currently
stress plus rest creates the performance
gains not just the stress which is
called training yeah you get faster and
stronger in the periods between your
workouts out during your workout but I
think one of the kind of underrated or
underappreciated aspects of
participating in in in these kinds of
sports is that it really does Drive you
to connect with yourself in a way that
most people don't like we're just we're
all in our heads you know we're in our
cars we're
earbuds in we're sitting at our desks
and we're not sort of inclined to pay
attention to the signals that our body
is sending us and it's not until you
sign up for a race and you start taking
your preparation seriously that you be
cut like this extra sense comes alive
where you start to like paint like why
am I feeling this way and and the more
you can kind of journal that and and
really listen to those signals you know
it doesn't happen overnight but you get
to learn you know and over doing this
for many many years like I know you know
like I know exactly when I feel a
certain way like when I need a day off
and I know it's like I think that the
hard part for a lot of people is that
dividing line between I'm just lazy and
I don't want to do it versus when you
are over drained I think those people I
will say like I'm over trained when
they're really just making an excuse for
themselves but then there really is you
know overtraining is real and you can
run yourself into a rut and get sick and
injured and all that kind of stuff so
understanding which is which really just
comes with time and and you know years
of listening to yourself yeah listening
takes practice whether it's in training
and sports or your partner or however it
listening takes practice and being able
to hear your body's signals takes
practice that's why most people freak
out in a taper because the volume comes
back ever so gently gradually and they
expect because the volume came back they
should suddenly feel better right well
I've had three lighter days why am I not
getting faster yet well you're so far
removed from your fresh self it's gonna
feel awful for the next few days yeah
and your body's gonna be sending you all
kinds of mixed signals it doesn't know
are we going back up in volume here
after these three days off like we have
been or are we going all the way down or
it's just completely confused and
usually a good taper I would say 72 to
48 hours out you start feeling good
right now before that yeah and many
think oh I have three fighter days or
two recovery days I should be flying
right and you start panicking exactly
yeah yeah and I think you know look
sleep and nutrition are the most
important things as a
sexy as they are you know we want to
talk about Norma tech boots and you know
whatever crazy new technology is is
happening or ancient technology cupping
and acupuncture and all of those things
are great and they have their place and
they're beneficial but ultimately like
if all you can do is ensure that you're
getting eight eight hours of sleep and
you're eating real food yeah then you
know you've got it you're 90 to 95
percent there yeah I was just gonna say
that's more than the 8020 rule if you're
doing sleep and nutrition to the best of
your ability
you're 90 percent there right and the
main remaining 10% yes that's when
you're really looking to dial it in and
add that last component but again if
we're looking to complete an ultra
endurance adventure do the 90 percent
yeah don't worry about that last time
yeah especially if you're on a budget or
your time cause all that kind of stuff
but on the subject of technology like a
big kind of recurring question thread
was all about the gear right do I need a
heartrate monitor what kind should I get
you know every time I post on Instagram
like a picture of my watch from a
workout it's like thirty crotchet which
what watch is that one push is that what
yeah there's a lot of focus on the gear
power meters and then the data what can
we learn from the data heart rate
variability and all that kind of stuff
and we've you know we've explored this
at length you know in the past but I
think it's worth kind of you know
refreshing some perspective on this
these are tools and they they they have
their place in the toolkit but once we
become dependent on them or we we become
focused on them or we feel like we have
to have them in order to train I think
you've kind of lost the plot and you
know I'll turn it over to you by just
saying this like when we were growing up
as swimmers you know you become so we're
talking about that like my body
you know connection that you get I know
and you know that after many many years
of swimming back and forth in a pool
that if somebody said okay you know do
this hundred in a minute or do it in 55
or do it in 110 that you could hit it
within a second and it would also know
exactly what your heart rate
yeah without any devices because you're
just you that connection is so strong
and I think these tools can help you
forge that connection but if you're
using them and you're so reliant on them
that you're you're not connecting with
yourself in that way I think you're
missing the point
yeah they're tools they shouldn't
dictate the workout they should help you
do the workout better right and so if
you want to be in a zone whether that's
on to zone 3 zone 4 they will help
calibrate your sensations with what's
actually happening and the to calibrate
itself you don't need one to dictate the
workout just because it says zone 3 or
zone 4 but you're getting sick you're
getting injured you're completely
fatigued you didn't get a lot of sleep
last night you have young kids and got
no sleep whatever there could be a
zillion reasons where you say you know
what this might not be the best choice
right now in how I'm doing this workout
I'm gonna listen to my body and when it
comes back in tune and the heart rate
monitor and so forth
it works well right just a quick
question by the way why hearts is
swimming I was thinking today because I
just swam do you swim with your eyes
open or closed eyes open okay I swim my
eyes closed do you yeah because when you
were just saying we know exactly with a
minute or 58 I was thinking today I'm
swimming with my eyes closed in a
completely random pool right Polly hi in
this case um and I just know when to
open my eyes for the turn just cuz I'm
so used to how many the timing of I'm
getting close to the other end and I
open my eyes back up I don't really have
you always done that
i I pretty much remember exactly how in
50-meter pools I always loved it because
I can close my eyes longer right that's
amazing I didn't know I mean I love a
peek a little bit to make sure I'm on
the black line with or not on the box
you can't be doing that when when
they're on a ground line but even
they're really yeah wow that's crazy man
that's why I was just thinking about
that when you said that closed eyes
swimming yeah so do you still train with
you know power and heart rate and all
that kind of stuff or lessons yeah I
just tested a few weeks ago to get my
our zones and that's manly again just to
see where I'm at a lot of that my
athletes ask me well what is your test
mean or what is my test mean it's just a
snapshot of who I currently am and where
I need to Train and in order to maximize
the limited time that we all have it's
great to have some inputs to quantify
and dig deeper into this will have the
most effect in the limited hours of
training we have right well on the
subject of training zones maybe we could
talk a little bit about zone 2 everyone
wants to talk about zone 2 it's the
constant theme yeah and and because I
wrote about it in my book maybe I didn't
explain it as in-depth as you would have
I feel like there's a lot of confusion
out there and some of the questions were
about you know do I train in zone 2 if
I'm training for a 10k or a half
marathon should I be you know this idea
of like slowing down to go fast to
create efficiency and aerobic capacity
what's your perspective maybe in a kind
of just a general sense and then we can
drill down on a some more specific
aspects of it well the important thing
with regards to zone 2 is as you're
getting fitter you're getting stronger
and in that heart rate zone you're going
to get faster now it might not be the
numbers and speed that you want to see
for your half marathon or you know
shorter events and so forth but you're
building a platform to then be better at
the zone 3a tempo pace running your
ligaments your cartilage your blood flow
your capillaries all that is gonna work
better because you created a better
foundation at zone 2 I think there's
also confusion about how to figure out
what your zone 2 is and you know because
I said in my book that mine was like you
know I kept my hurry at 1:40
that's my zone 2 or at least it was a
while ago yeah I don't think we tested
in a while for somebody who's listening
your zone 2 could be completely
different you know that the top end of
your zone 2 might be a hundred and
seventy beats per minute it might be 120
and really the only way to determine
that is to be properly tested the ideal
way to do that is to get a formal proper
lactate test that you can do
most big cities or university towns
there is the capability to do that but
if somebody's listening and they want to
do their DIY version of that what's the
best way because people ask me that all
the time I've found that doing five one
mile repeats for the Europeans I would
even do two kilometers but you can keep
it to 1600 meters at a track with
one-minute rest at 90 to 95 percent
effort so about 10k effort not 10k pace
because you don't want to start these
5-1 mile repeats at an at a pace because
in your monitoring you're controlling
the output it should be pretty hard and
the average of that pace and the
averages of that heart rate it gets us
pretty close to what's called threshold
heart rate zone for in this case and
around there's your anaerobic threshold
anaerobic threshold others know it as
lactate threshold and from there we
deduce back to zone 2 and over the years
I've gotten to a point where it's not
only quite close because I've done
literally thousands of these that after
a while the athlete actually says do I
really need to pay $200 write data but
also I also separate the zones by five
to seven beats so that people don't get
into the gray area between zones so when
you do that you get your zone four then
you can dial it back to see where zone
three is and Zone two is and it works
quite well it's usually a good 30 40 35
beats below you're a lactate threshold
zone for anaerobic threshold all right
so you're doing these mile or two
kilometer repeats so we're certain you
run hurry home nurse best-effort right
and if you're recording your heart rate
after each and your pace after each and
we don't necessarily use the pace to
determine the zones or we don't but when
you do the tests again on your own in
six to eight weeks you want to see the
pace have improved either at the same
heart rate zones or same pace but the
heart rate zones are lower usually very
rarely do we see the heart rate zone and
zones go lower at the same pace because
you're still going
at almost best-effort so the heart rate
is still gonna kick really high right
and so the pace goes down and it's
always startling because the athlete
will say that's strange because I did
zero speed work yet I'm getting faster
mm-hmm at these high efforts by just
doing zone to work and that answers that
half marathon question - you are
teaching yourself to become so aerobic
ly economical that going faster will
become more efficient as well right
that's the thing that people have a hard
time believing especially when they
begin this journey and they realize like
to remain in their zone - they're
literally walk crawling yeah and and
most people don't have the discipline to
stick it out like they abandon it before
the miracle I described the zones when
they when we often do that track test
before I put them into a lab right
because it might be a little bit
overwhelming for somebody who's brand
new to this to ask them for blood drawn
or like they've not like just long ago
man I just want to do a 10k freaking
exactly so empathy Chris can see look
look
yeah I'm growing but I'll describe Zone
two as so I'll say zone to the heart
rate zone and I say the description is
you should be frustrated on how slow
this is it should feel like a waste of a
workout mmm then you did zone - perfect
right okay and as you become more and
more adept at it over somebody's been
doing this for years and years and years
what is amazing is that yeah you start
out like oh I can't you know if I go
faster than a 10-minute mile my heart
rates too high yeah this is ridiculous
you know six months later you're running
nine minutes you know a year and a half
later you're running eight minutes and
then you're down to seven minute pace
and it doesn't feel as easy as that ten
minutes it feels hard or not not super
hard but your heart rate is still in
zone - you know like how is that
possible when I didn't do any track work
when I wasn't like busting 400 meter
repeats or anything like that so you
truly do get faster it's a long game
though well yeah playing the long game
here playing the long game but the the
results are all so long
because the work that you're doing
inside your body the oxygen uptake the
blood flow and so forth the
mitochondrial very long last thing yeah
now if you stop doing everything it'll
go away in a couple of weeks but the the
platform that you're building allows you
to take on so many other stresses from a
physical standpoint from training that
it is really long-lasting with regards
to what you're capable of I have
athletes who say I haven't done any type
of mountain climbing in years but then
they'll do something crazy up in the
mountains all off his own to training
right yeah and you know I'm I'm you know
everything that I was able to accomplish
was by sticking to that plan at some
point when you reach a certain level of
vacuity though then you can build in the
speed work as well sure yo sure so it's
not just only that for whatever you're
trying to course not
absolutely not no you want leg turnover
you want higher intensity stuff you want
things that really stress the system
it's just a question of how much time
you're doing that you know 80% of the
time zone to 20% of time zone 4 or above
or 90/10 or 60/40 and then that's where
it goes into what kind of race you're
doing right if you're doing an Olympic
distance triathlon or if you're doing a
marathon run or if you're doing you know
a 3k open water swim well then it's
probably more like 6040 5050 zone to
time and then intensity time mm-hmm but
if you're doing something super long
you're gonna increase that zone to
aerobic activity but you still want like
turnover you still want that the o2
effort so that your oxygen uptake also
gets the other side of the spectrum it's
just so taxing on the system that you
have to be very careful on how long they
are how much recovery you're getting and
how frequently you're doing them right
and I think another kind of benefit of
the zone to training is it prepares your
your joints and your ligaments over time
to manage a greater load as you begin to
escalate right rather than just going
out and hammering it that it provides
better consistency because you stay
healthier and you can come back the next
day and
repeat the workout day after day after
day build layer upon layer upon layer
and the other discipline it builds is
your mind if you can show the resilience
early on to stick to your zones mhm
your ability to stick to your pacing for
an 8 9 10 15 hour event will be a lot
better right because you're gonna be
able to start slow and finish fast yeah
everybody thinks discipline is being
super hardcore but it's really just
control it's how you modulate all of
this and being able to you know sit the
ego down and do you know what is on the
piece of paper for you to do even if you
think like oh I want to go harder or I
want to go slower well and and in the
endurance races that are out there
whether running swimming biking
triathlon whatever it is finishing fast
feels way better than getting past and
slowing down and your ability to not
slow down as we've said before that you
can work through that in your mind but
also motivationally getting past
continuously and beat up and I want you
to last in this sport I want you to sign
up for the next event because you felt
good and energetic and enjoyed it and
you were passing people over the last
few miles right that's gonna keep you in
this sport keep you healthy keep you
growing your endurance keep you
motivated not walking and you know
nothing worse than she the cheers of you
can do it you're looking great and doing
it yeah you know you are and what and
you know you could technically run but
you just pasted it wrong right and those
tears aren't for you to finish your
those tears you're feeling awful your
head is down and you're miserable yeah
we don't want that so just to put the
nail in the coffin on this subject and
for people that are perhaps brand new to
this podcast or to Chris and I the thing
is is that most amateur sort of armchair
newbie triathletes marathon runners
runners make the mistake of spending
ninety to a hundred percent of their
training time in what is affectionately
called the gray zone yeah it's that
of effort that leaves you feeling good
if you go out and run for a half an hour
45 minutes or an hour it's a good strong
pace and when you finish you feel like
you accomplished something but in truth
you're really undercutting the your
optimal sort of accessing your optimal
potential because you're going too fast
to truly develop that aerobic engine
you're above z2 but you're not going
hard or fast enough to truly develop the
anaerobic engine so you're kind of in
the middle you're getting a little bit
of benefit from both but ultimately if
you persist in just doing that all the
time you will quickly plateau and you
will never actualize your potential as
an athlete I think that's the number one
mistake that most most most of the kind
of new people to the sport make yeah the
classic too easy on hard days too hard
on easy day so you're stuck in that grey
zone there was grit just another article
out there on that I sent out to all my
athletes addressing exactly this I mean
it's constantly being reminded of us
that if you're gonna train like an
athlete that means that you're gonna
train smart and deliberately then you
need to go hard enough on hard days and
therefore you'll be begging for the easy
days but you can't go too easy on hard
days and too hard on easy days yeah I
think people even when they understand
that they still go too hard on the easy
days yeah and then when you show up for
that hard day you're not sharp enough to
really push it as hard as you could
otherwise and you're unmotivated once
again the motivation wanes when you
don't see the progress that you want to
see or your others are beating you are
going faster than you and you're like
what am I doing wrong right I call it
exercises exercising versus training
mm-hmm people who have no deliberate
outcome with regards to their workout
with regards to their training with
their eyes to their zones and just go do
their exercising but training has a
prescription training has a desired
outcome training is a puzzle piece that
fixing it fits into the bigger picture
and if you're going too hard on easy
days and too easy on hard days you're
exercising yeah it's really an exercise
in as well as in in checking your ego
yeah especially in the era of Strava you
know everybody wants to post you know
the epic workout and if you're on a
program and it's an easy day like you
can't go for that kom or whatever you
can't be thinking about like what your
friends are gonna think and you gotta
let that other person pass you and again
it goes back to having that kind of
discipline and intentionality what is
the purpose of that workout and are you
meeting that and how does that fit into
the week because on Thursday or on
Friday you might have a really important
workout that you've been eyeing and your
coaches been eyeing and you're excited
to do but if the lead-up isn't done
right next thing you know that's not
being absorbed properly and it has
downstream effects right and again then
you're not training then you're just
going through the motions and a lot of
times athletes they struggle with
confidence already because they're new
to this whole ultra endurance world as
well as just being athletes at this
stage in life and so confidence is an
important part when we do the
simulations
I want them coming out of that having
learned something gained confidence and
excited for the next phase of training
if that's not happening because they're
going too hard well we're just treading
water because they're not getting more
confident they're not having the
adaptations we're looking for and then
I'm looking at the training plan going
what am I missing here what did I do
wrong I I started asking did you eat
what's your nutrition like are you
sleeping yes check check check and then
I start seeing right this drama files
there you go all right here's a question
from Paris Lyle's
what are the top five most important
things you should be doing if you are
new to endurance sports five five can
you come well number one is consistency
right you want to be able to find the
ability to do it back to back to back to
layer upon layer and it doesn't need to
be a lot of hours I mean we have people
that think they need to train 15 to 20
plus hours in order to do that but
thirty minutes a day twenty minutes a
day is plenty good but if you can come
back the next day and do something
aerobic again and remember aerobic
doesn't mean you're only cycling or run
or swimming your heart doesn't know
which activity you're doing as long as
you're in that zone right you can be
doing jumping jacks hmm if your heart
rates up in that zone it's just pumping
it's doing its work but it could be any
of many sports so consistency is
important the recovery in the sleep I
think is very important I think
nutrition more important
vital that is to any type of performance
that we're asking from this amazing tool
called our body right you've got to fuel
it effectively and a lot of people seem
to think as younger people like I can
throw anything and I'm training tons of
hours and it doesn't really matter well
you wouldn't put crap in your car right
right or and ask it to do well at the
track same thing with fueling your body
and taking care of this precious thing
because in 20 years from now it's gonna
wonder what you did to it so now we're
three you have anything add four four
and five while I'm thinking about it I
think a big one is not getting caught up
in the gear I have to that's the first
one because that acts as a barrier or an
excuse for a lot of people like well you
know I can't get into it yet because I
can't afford this or I can't afford that
or what's the best running shoe and
those become those become impediments to
just getting out and beginning yeah so
don't worry about the gear work with
whatever you have yeah that stuff comes
later if you get more enthusiastic and
more kind of invested then you can have
that conversation and explore that but
but just begin I think is the other
thing and that kind of dovetails into
the second point that I was gonna make
which is you don't need all of your
questions answered but we're beginning
either especially when you're new yeah
you want to know exactly where you're
heading what it's going to look like
every question that you have and you're
gonna have a million questions and
that's normal will be answered as well
over time and so again don't use that as
a barrier to just signing up for a race
and getting started yeah yeah and
beating yourself up about the workouts
too much
is a big issue and sort of what you were
just saying getting started is the key
but then life will get in the way and
you will miss a workout and therefore
you didn't get all the layers going as
you want that doesn't mean you can't
restart or get three days in a row
or get four days in a row or go back to
two days in a row it's all making a
difference right I like flexible in
value exactly
well that whether that comes with
balance as well as what I always like to
say is progress not perfection
be a little bit better today than you
were yesterday and that 20 minute jog
makes you better than yesterday because
it accumulated on where you were
yesterday and progress not just
perfection it starts this this snowball
to an avalanche of getting fit what
about people that you know can't afford
to hire someone like yourself they want
to run a marathon they want to do an
Ironman whatever it is that they want to
do there's so many training programs
online I mean I haven't really because I
have you I don't go and look at all that
kind of stuff
I know there's tons out there and I'm
sure some of them are good and some of
them aren't so good so if somebody's
trying to figure that out for themselves
what is your advice well there's two
things one is back to that progress not
perfection a lot of the training plans
that are out there just because you're
not hitting every single last detail
doesn't mean you're not getting a
benefit use it as a guide and do the
best you can it will help you just to
get out there and do it consistently and
then you know if you're looking at a
training plan to do a sub three hour
marathon on your first marathon that
might not be the right thing so you know
horses for courses find your proper book
or find the proper online program that
sort of is more conservative if you
train too slow
it won't hurt you if you train too hard
it will likely hurt you
you'll get injured you'll get
demotivated or you won't have the
progress that you're looking for are
there any training programs that you're
aware of like specific ones that you
think are good that you can recommend or
now it's hard for me because I never
ever look at those things myself I mean
I purposely and and you we've talked
about this before and I've talked to a
lot of other coaches about this before
whether it's at conferences and so on I
look at nothing I look at nothing cuz I
like to keep it really creative and
individual to me and the more I know
what others are doing or how they're
doing it it makes me lose sort of how
I'm trying to apply it off the things
I'm experimenting and learning from yeah
I mean one of the things that I've
learned through you is it's it's a
dynamic you know it's a partnership and
it's dynamic and it's evolving and it's
it is it's responsive to where the
athlete is so it's not like oh right
you're doing Ultraman well here's your
plan all the way to the end it's like
you kind of plan it out 7 or 10 days
ahead and then you're like well let's
look at where you're at and then I can
decide what you're gonna be doing for
the next I mean there is a meta like I
know where we're trying to get and I
have an idea of these training blocks
that I want to put in but it's not like
you've scripted the whole program no way
to the yellow everybody's so individual
and has so many different needs and
things that get in the way and many of
my athletes know the wording of wedge
week that I call it we get sick a
project at work something of our
children I call it a wedge week those
weeks we're gonna fall off and volume
that's fine take a wedge week and relax
about it don't get overwhelmed and
frustrated and stressed about it and now
I can't do the event it's just the week
won't get you fit again that's not the
issue and the other thing that you were
saying before which I wanted to get back
to with regards to the nature aspect not
all of us have access to nature the way
we do with regards to getting out and
running and cycling in open roads but if
you can get it every now and then every
2 or 3 weeks if you're living in
Manhattan getting north out into upstate
New York or getting out over to New
Jersey getting some fresh air and
getting out there it makes a difference
not just the treadmill not just the
indoor cycling classes you know and not
just an indoor pool so with regards to
means and not having the availability
whether financially or just location
wise still try to get that invigorating
immersive experience
occasionally because that will help you
deal with being back in your basement on
the trainer or on the treadmill injury
let's talk about that for a little bit
kind of came up a second ago there were
a bunch of questions about persistent
injuries somebody was like my calf keeps
and getting injured or coming back from
injury so first of all let's take that
first piece like people who are
consistently persistently getting
injured in the same way time and time
again yeah I would look at your training
your habits on how you're training I
would definitely look at nutrition and I
would also look at some other imbalances
in the body on why this keeps coming up
oftentimes just because you have a calf
injury doesn't mean it's in the calf
absolutely and so once you sort of again
start listening to your body and sort of
ruling out certain things and being
smart about recovery and resting when
niggles come up because in ultra
endurance training and we were talking
about this earlier in ultra endurance
training the volume that you're doing
eventually even if you're just starting
out it's new to you so it is volume for
you the body the the volume will find
the injury it will find the weak spot
and if you have a hip injury or if you
have a knee thing or if you have a shin
splint or if you have a potential for a
stress fracture coming out it's coming
because the volume will find it the
pounding on the body will find it so
when you listen to your body and you
hear it coming you've got to take action
right and not just dr. Google but rest
right not right away I think the sky is
falling rest and see how your body
responds to that rest and allow it to
come back and with regards to coming
back from injury again patience and
discipline and allowing everything to
come back in a more holistic way with
other imbalances being worked out and
core instability I have an athlete
currently she has a stress fracture in
her femur and she was very upset you
know it's like her season is definitely
limited now right but instead we had a
conversation
listen I'll get you fit again this is
not a question of getting you fit let's
use this time for opportunity catch up
with your family catch up on other
things shame on you
I know I know how dare I say that um you
know spend some time volunteering doing
different things work on your swimming
take some you know knitting lessons
whatever it is but just use the time to
sort of say you know what I'm gonna turn
this injury into something positive
mm-hmm and coming back you have to be
really smart like not just pound right
back in but really have a deliberate
plan over six eight 12 weeks at which
point I want to be back to par fitness
what I call it mmm and depending on the
injury and your body and what you know
of your history that might be 12 weeks
away so now how am i structuring the
next 12 weeks so that I'd gradually
build up come back down again gradually
build up more come back down again
all the while listening to how my body
is responding hmm yeah Buerkle was a
great example of that because she's been
in that freakin boot for like a year and
she's a racehorse you know so to tell a
girl like that Olympic athlete like you
just you can't do all the stuff that
you're used to doing all day long every
day
it was I think it was a really huge
emotional challenge for her and she
chose to kind of share it openly on
social media which I thought was really
cool like like how difficult it was for
her but also to treat it as a growth
opportunity yeah to grow in other areas
it's really cool and it's like look if
you're in the game for you know any
extended period of time stuff like this
happens yeah and out of fairness to her
is that she's also been wired all her
life that a people have taken care of
her injuries because she's in the sort
of the Olympic system and there's people
with eyes on it and paying attention and
monitoring and blood tests and you know
so forth but also that her wiring has
always been okay I recovered now I
trained again yeah right and in our
sport of swimming it's pretty hard that
when there's no pounding on the body to
really not gradually just jump right
back in and so with something like
running and where our full body weight
is back involve
things are dramatically different yeah
on the subject of the persistent injury
you know in terms of coming back I think
that you know obviously you know taking
enough time to rest is important but on
that subject of like imbalances you know
when you said like well if it's the calf
it's not necessarily the calf it's an
imbalance like if your spine is out of
alignment if you have one hip where your
muscles are too tight it's creating this
weird asymmetry in your body and that
might be fine if all you're doing is
walking around and living your life but
when you're doing the pounding and all
of that over time that's gonna manifest
in that injury and you can rest and let
it heal but it's gonna happen again the
follow you know if I rest that and and
really figure that out and that goes to
you know the stretching and and the
function will strength work to make sure
your core is strong and whether it's
going to a cairo and looking at your
spine and seeing if you have a curvature
there like they can really evaluate if
you're a little bit often even if you're
even if your hips are tilted you know a
centimeter now if you're trying to train
for an ultra like you're gonna have a
problems and because of strides
absolutely and you know good sports
medicine physical therapists they can
quickly test a lot of strength
components on your body how your hip
flexors are firing how your hamstrings
are firing how your calves are
supporting how your plantar supporting
they within 45 minutes can give you a
protocol that basically shows you these
are your imbalances these are the things
you need to work on in order to create a
more balanced body right so even if you
don't have that you know you have a
curved spine and you're if you did an
x-ray it looks like everything's in
check if you're weak in your core or in
your functional strength when you go out
and train and you start to fatigue your
technique denigrates right you start to
like each over when you use the big
muscles right and then that's gonna lead
to a problem where that weaker muscle is
going to contribute to an injury yep so
it'll find it it'll find it it's just
because of the hours and the time out
there the body will find the injury when
you're doing that much pounding 40 times
your body
is what running is mom the ankles on the
knees and so forth so that's a lot of
weight to consider that your poor joints
have to carry that and how that sort of
shoots through the rest of your body
whether it's hip whether its knee or
there it's lower back right and if
there's an imbalance it'll find it right
all right we got time for a couple more
here one I think that would be good is
is how to maintain your enthusiasm stay
engaged with the sport after you've just
completed a race or perhaps when your
motivation is waning yeah well I mean
for me I've a lot of my athletes know
this I'm just such a big believer in the
journey and what we're doing and why
we're doing it if we're looking for just
that specific outcome and we don't know
that life goes beyond on after that
certain day it's gonna be really tough
when that day comes and passes and you
feel no different sure you're proud of
your accomplishment and don't get me
wrong I believe in being proud of the
work you've done
I'm putting meaning behind it and
purpose and belief behind it because if
it's important to you that's good enough
right but as we're training through
these ultra endurance events what I was
writing about is it's that beauty it's
feeling that alive and invigorated and
if you're missing that you're not
listening to your body you're not being
present like we talked about with how
lucky you are to do be doing this
training outside in nature immersing
yourself in it and feeling that dopamine
release that will want you coming back
if you're just doing it in the gym in a
box somewhere you don't get that same
release you don't get that same stimulus
and you don't feel that vibrancy that is
in you that you get from finishing a
long workout you might be tired but you
still feel awesome yeah I also think
that it's important to really inventory
the extent to which you're kind of
growing as a person by virtue of doing
this like are you becoming a better
person
is it enriching your life because I
think there's an epidemic in endurance
sports of people using it almost like a
drug to run a
away from other aspects of their life
whether they're in an unhappy
relationship or they hate their job or
they have just some you know trauma in
their life that they can't gather this
drink to confront so you can use this
sport as a distraction from your life
and I see that a lot and I think it
probably doesn't get discussed enough so
it really is important for you to be
honest with yourself like are you using
it are you participating in it in a
healthy way
motivation will wane at just the nature
of motivation it's a short-term thing
but how you are in the sport why you're
in the sport I ask all my athletes the
meaning of why they're doing this what's
their meaning behind it not their goals
not their but what connects them to it
why did they choose this why that event
what's the meaning behind it and many
don't have that answer but when they do
go through the exercise of understanding
yeah why am I doing this
yeah I think they grow as athletes like
you were saying and then they have a
whole different appreciation for it
because guess what that Kona slot once
you have it life goes on on the other
side yeah it's not like I mean you know
yeah you still are going back to your
life out of that right yeah so what is
your life look like yep you know alright
last question do you sleep in a tent no
I know you don't Chris is not although
Chris probably spends more time out
camping in in nature than I do I
definitely like it outside yeah yeah
when I was thinking about remember I was
talking to you about running the John
Muir Trail this yeah so that hasn't come
up it's still something I want to do and
no not for some sort of you know fastest
known time or to put some sort of record
out there but again just to be out there
and not that I'm again like what you
were just saying getting a lost from
anything or from hiding from anything
but more because I love being out there
and experiencing it and feeling it and
having an opportunity come back then and
share that with others and inspire them
through my energy to get out there as
well cool awesome man so I think I want
to close this down by sharing a few
thoughts on a blog post that I came
across that was written by Jason coop
mm-hmm and we're both friends with
Jason's an amazing ultra runner as well
as endurance coach at Carmichael systems
I got to know him when we were pacing
Dean Karnazes at bad water so I spent a
couple days with him super cool guy
incredible athlete and he wrote this
post that I'll link up in the show know
it's called best advice eight coaches
give their single best tips and he
basically just conducted a recent ultra
running camp and he asked all of his
sort of fellow coaches that were hosting
this camp like what is their best single
piece of advice and there were some
really cool nuggets in here the first
one was don't count yourself out right
so what I think about that well it just
be confident in yourself and the other
aspect what he's probably I'm talking
about there is it's a long event and
just because you go through one Valley
there's plenty of Peaks ahead and you
can have a slow first half and still win
a race mhm
you know that's the beauty of ultra
endurance nothing is over until way way
way further down the line yeah I just
had des Linden in here two days ago so
we're talking about that very thing like
you know she was like this race is not
happening for me and she starts
sacrificing herself for everybody else
except herself only to find herself you
know within striking range at you know
with at Mile 22 and takes the lead I
know it was incredible right so yeah the
peaks and the valleys just because you
feel lousy it's a long day it doesn't
mean that you know it's gonna it's it
will change and you could come back to
life you hear it all the time in the
fitter you are the more time that you
have spent in zi2 the more likely you
are to be able to resuscitate yourself
and come back I think so not judging
yourself and like ganging up on yourself
emotionally obviously when that happens
it's an emotional day in general so of
course there's gonna be peaks and
valleys it's so immersive and there's so
much going on and you sacrifice so much
to get ready for this
you should be emotional
but allow yourself the full event mm-hmm
embrace what is difficult and
uncomfortable and love Darcy Murphy I
love that it just makes you stronger
right your ability to deal with
adversity right and like I was writing
earlier your ability to deal with
adversity and be vulnerable just makes
you a better person on the other side
learning how to swim for the first time
doing your first ultra feeling foolish
doing something on a bike not knowing
how to clip in your pedals all those
things feeling vulnerable just makes you
realize oh man maybe I should be more
empathetic to people this great epiphany
that yeah it's crazy amazing I mean that
was a big theme of my recent
conversation with Jessie it's leur who I
know you know as well you know his his
his constant you know sort of push to
put himself in uncomfortable situations
and when you do that time slows down
like because you're and you you come
alive in a way that you just don't when
you're stuck in your routine and what I
said earlier what do we have these days
that really create fear and challenge in
us a work project doesn't create fear
and challenge our family and life and
community life doesn't really create
fear and challenge but we as human
beings as animals we are wired to deal
with fear and challenge and that just
makes us more alive and connect with
parts of us that we didn't even realize
we had because we've overcome adversity
and embrace those challenges but it
contradicts every message that were
exposed to every single day that pushes
us towards luxury and comfort and ease
it's like it's an intuitive it's part of
it yeah and part of it it's part of it
yeah mm-hmm
this one I love for every one minute you
spend training your body spend two
minutes training your mind
yeah that's means a great way to say it
but I also think you get the benefits of
one-to-one like you don't literally have
to set the clock but you're training
your mind at the same time all the time
and understanding and listening again to
your mind is a very hard thing to do and
that's why the longer
you go into ultra-endurance the more you
have that opportunity to spend some time
inside your head when you're running
through the night or you're out in a
trail for hours upon hours whether
you're hiking running however you're
cycling in the middle of nowhere
your brain starts working inwards and
starts just listening to what the
thoughts are and clearing things out
it's a very meditative process but it's
also very important for us and every
time you confront and overcome some kind
of mental barrier or you accomplish
something that you didn't think that you
could
that's like push-ups for the soul right
you've then had that experience and your
perception of your capabilities and what
is normal shifts yeah the new normal the
new floor right what used to be far a
10k now you're running marathons you
think 10k I can do a 10k and it
continues to grow like that brain is the
same way the iron cowboy James Lawrence
was in town the other day giving a talk
so I went to introduce him just kind of
you know provide a little introduction
to him and do a little host a little Q&A
after his talk and I'd never watched him
do he does like a full keynote like
presentation and I watched him deliver
like it was really it was it was it was
quite something like he really figured
out how to tell this story about doing
50 my man's in 50 days in 50 states and
you know very well but the predominant
kind of overarching theme of the whole
thing boils down to you know really the
mental game like what he had to confront
in his mind in order to accomplish that
and that really took primacy over the
you know we all think of it as being
this impossible physical challenge but
it was his mind that really allowed him
to carry it and understanding how to
develop that level of like mental
resilience is the differentiator between
people like him or David Goggins or
these other people that do all these
amazing things and everybody else yeah I
mean your ability to come back and deal
with the pain and deal with the
adversity and deal with the fatigue and
also deal with the unser
t-that builds incredible strength
incredible strength that you can apply
everywhere mm-hmm you know the next one
on this list is cultivate grit which is
kind of similar to what we just talked
about yeah yeah be vigilant though is a
big part of of grit and that is not
allowing the internal narrative to talk
you out of anything mm-hmm surround
yourself with good people good code you
ought to be good coaching that's
certainly one person that you need but
you also don't want to be around people
that pull your dreams and desired
outcomes of ours right energy-sucking
versus energy giving and that believe in
you and grow your confidence because
again if it's meaningful to you that's
enough be proud of that accomplish that
goal and be proud that you stuck stuck
your mind you're yourself out there in
order to accomplish the goal and did it
it's a great thing
there's the adage that you are the
average of the five people that you
spend the most time with which I think
speaks to that but beyond that I think
also it's worth stating that whatever
challenge you're facing you know
endurance challenge ultra endurance
challenge that it is you and it is an
individual sport and yet it's not it's
yeah it is a team sport you know whether
you need formal crew or you don't it
doesn't matter the people that you have
surrounded yourself with that you're
spending the most time with whether they
are directly or indirectly involved in
the pursuit of that goal the quality and
caliber of those relationships are
integral and and often determinative in
terms of whether you're going to achieve
that goal or not and it's part of that
balance if you're out of balance there
and you take too much energy from your
support around you your family your work
you're not going to be able to sustain
it
yeah the next one is kind of obvious be
really really physically prepared well
yeah I mean it's sort of what we said
last year furtillo right I mean I'd
rather be over-prepared mm-hmm and deal
with the things that I can't control on
race day versus be underprepared and
sort of flailing right yeah there's an
the idea of lining you know it's toeing
the line at the start line knowing that
you're not physically prepared and many
people have something I have the ability
to do that yeah figure it out but their
desired outcome is usually not being met
the next one is from Jason adapt
you know you there's many things in
ultra endurance events and especially
ultra running which what he's talking
about that you cannot control on race
day on event day I call it I don't like
to call it race day an event day because
weather and terrain and competitors in
your stomach and niggles all those
things can come up right and we've
trained so much for this one day for
this event day and you have to be ready
to adapt and to all the things that will
go wrong things will go wrong it's too
much distance it's too much terrain it's
in the middle of nowhere usually you're
not doing a 50-miler in on a track in
downtown San Diego so be ready for that
but that's where the Fitness ties in if
you have the fitness and a really strong
platform to go from you will be able to
think better and adapt to make better
decisions when those things go wrong
right
that's what why I believe so much in the
this huge level of fitness is your
thinking ability becomes stays really
strong when things start going right and
and part and parcel of the mental
preparation for such an event requires
kind of mindfully developing your
emotional agility so that you're not
even if you are thinking clearly it's
you could still be an emotional wreck
and get them out of your game so the
more you can kind of train yourself to
roll with whatever gets thrown in your
direction the better off you're gonna be
able to quickly adapt I mean sometimes
you can kind of physically adapt but if
you're so like sort of distraught over
what you just had to do to get back on
track that's gonna take its toll the
more you can just be like a river you
know and flow with whatever comes every
day is an opportunity to improve to be
better than you were yesterday and it
might not just be in training it's the
things that you're talking about being
mentally more prepared for adversity
today than I was yesterday because I
went
out there in the rain or I dealt with
that blister while I was running today
or that flat tire happened I fixed it
and I kept riding although usually I
would call for a ride to get home
there's a zillion ways we can spin these
stories but there's always a nugget in
there that makes us stronger makes us
better perfect prepared for the event or
just in general makes us a better
prepared person right rather than
getting pissed when that happens in
training oh here's my opportunity to
learn how to deal with this stuff better
right the next one is learn to love the
process and I think that's great because
it speaks to the why that we talked
about and I think it's important if you
want to stay in the game and have any
kind of like longevity but I think where
it gets interesting is where you
bifurcate loving the process with being
attached to you know an outcome because
on some level if you set a goal like
that that can be a very important
driving force like I want to have this
happen and that's what gets me out of
bed in the morning balancing that
against being sort of detached from that
outcome because that's not really the
real reason that you're in it yeah I
mean but also what you just said is
actually interesting I want this to
happen that's not saying I want to get
second place first place this time
because placing you don't control other
people who will be there right a time
you don't control the weather or the
conditions that day or you know a lot of
the things that are part of that wanting
something to happen is still sort of a
desired outcome there's ways to shift
that and I'm not saying to take to take
your goals and sort of make them less
meaningful but if you don't love the
process the trainings gonna be very
difficult in the ultra-endurance world
because what the one thing that I would
have probably added to that list that
coaches have all learned is what your
traits are in the rest of your life at
work or with family they rise to the yes
in ultra endurance training you can't
hide from you know and so if you don't
believe in the process and Trust the
and embrace the journey you're gonna
keep talking yourself out of things and
you're gonna stumble on the same things
you stumble on in communication at work
or you know with your family or it's
just all our traits come to the top
right and and that's why you know
endurance sports ultra ultra endurance I
mean they're really a metaphor for life
and all of these tips are equally
applicable to you know if you're not an
athlete and you're listening to this
like these this is good advice or
whatever it is that you're dealing with
or whatever it is you're trying to
accomplish in your life and let's before
we say something that we lose a couple
of listeners anybody can be an athlete
an athlete to me is being is a mindset
it's how I'm gonna prepare for the
workout that's how I'm gonna execute the
work out how I'm gonna recover from a
workout that could be for your first 5k
or that could be for the Olympics what
makes you an athlete is how you think
you prepare for it and think about it
and get through it not because you're
some sort of elite status or you have a
certain physical stature or something
like that anybody can be an athlete
that's beautiful man I'm glad that you
pointed that out and I think it's a good
place to end it with one caveat which is
that there is one more piece of advice
on this list yeah and what's so
poetically beautiful about it is that
the last piece of advice is practice
self empathy so you ended your post with
the word empathy and this list of eight
pieces of advice from Jason ends with a
little coming together yes it's all
coming again
so yes practice self empathy empathy for
others but empathy for self yeah forgive
yourself forgive yourself you can't you
can't do this if you're looking to be
too perfect you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes I've made so many mistakes in
25 years you're doing this and I
continue to make them every day mm-hmm
awesome Matt great to talk to you any
any uh any parting words you wanna know
I'm just still blown away by hearing you
read my words that was pretty I wouldn't
had anybody do that now you have to
publish it so I can link it up in the
shoto so everybody can read it yeah well
so you'll have to teach me how to do
that alright well we'll talk about it
offline yeah awesome man thank you so
much or super helpful inspirational and
always great to see you my friend
yeah cool so if you want to connect with
Chris the best way to do that is a iymp
coaching comm or an at AI MP coach on
twitter weekly word podcast
that's right weekly where I was your
podcast it's very good it's actually
going great I answer all these questions
you do every single time if you know
about right right right to it and and we
should point out that in going through
all the questions Chris had said oh well
I just answered that on my podcast so
there was a bunch that we skipped over
so if you feel like your question was
not answered what Chris does on his
podcast is really dive deep and get into
the into the weeds on all of this kind
of stuff that you guys out there who
want to geek out on endurance sports
would love so the weekly weekly word
podcast and get it on iTunes wherever
you listen to podcast yeah cool all
right man until next time yeah
peace
[Music]
you